temps place enfin au cinéma le festival
de cannes approche et on vient de
connaître la sélection officielle des
films français qui seront présentés
l'invitation en voyage de peter dale
montée douce enquête sur la violence de
gérard guérin et à toute allure de
robert kramer alain delon ses films vous
les connaissez des films vous voulez
bien seul et que ses trois filles moins
de cannes absolument pas donc vous êtes
presque aussi surpris que france font
suite à fait mais je le respecte l'avis
du comité de sélection de représenter la
france avec les sujets sûrement de haute
qualité
alors votre dernier film le choc sort
demain enceinte dans un mystère quasi
complet parce que personne ou presque à
part vous ne l'a vu ce film
non il n'y a pas eu de projection privée
n'y a pas eu de projection de presse mme
une projection dit de tout paris sait la
décision concertée des producteurs et de
moi même c'est un choix et nous l'avons
fait délibérément je crois que le film a
besoin de sa première audience de ce
premier contact avec le public et c'est
l'avis du public que nous attendons
avant tout on pouvait déjà dire de quoi
il s'agit mais c'est vraiment 6 passes
jusqu'à demain c'est le suspense ce sera
le suspense jusqu'à demain comme son
titre l'indiqué
j'espère que pour les spectateurs le
film sera un choc comme il s'intitule
disons que déjà c'est un choc de par la
rencontre ces deux comédiens de nature
tout à fait différente
c'est à mon avis une rencontre qui
s'imposait c'est ça du moins c'était un
choc pour moi
et disons que le film est un film qui je
crois sera passionnant parce que nous
l'avons voulu ainsi c'est un film
d'aventuré c'est un film d'action
je ne dirais pas un film de violence
parce que maintenant je crois que depuis
bien longtemps la fiction a est en
retrait de la réalité malheureusement et
que nous inspirons plus du dans le
cinéma des faits divers quotidiens alors
l'une des unes des séquences chocs de ce
film paraît-il
c'est la gifle que vous donnez à
catherine deneuve mais apparemment ce
qui vous a surpris c'est qu'elle vous a
giflé en retour
on ne m'a pas surpris puisque c'était
dans le scénario quand même on a dit que
vous n'aviez pas eu non plus écoutée
quand même je lis les scénarios c'est en
général ce que je tourne et ce que je
fais alors disons que ça n'a pas été une
surprise du tout mais je crois que ce
sera peut-être une surprise pour les
spectateurs
alors votre rôle c'est encore une fois
celui du du beau mâle avec un revolver
ou plusieurs revolver ou les beaux mâles
je le suis voilà alors revolver merci
christine les revolver je n'ai utilise
qu'au cinéma mais disons que c'est avant
tout si vous voulez quand même pour
répondre à une certaine demande par un
certain public mais je crois pouvoir
dire d'un public certains qui aiment
disons alain delon dans l'incertain
genre de film est dans un certain style
de film et je ne tiens pas avec celui là
plus qu'avec les précédents à le
décevoir
je crois que dans ce sens ils ne seront
pas déçus je fais du cinéma pour le
public je le dis je les ai déjà dit et
je le redis
là vous êtes parfois aussi producteur de
films bien que ce ne soit pas le cas des
sinus en une heure ça n'est pas le cas
de celui ci je me suis que modeste
interprète et j'en suis profondément
ravis puisque ça me permet de me
détendre et mes activités en tant que
producteur et en tant qu'acteur que
pensez vous de la réforme du cinéma qui
vient d'être mise en chantier par le
liste renée que je n'ai pas encore eu le
temps de me pencher sur le dossier du
ministre de la culture je ne lis pas
tellement je n'ai pas beaucoup monsieur
lang
ce que je peux vous dire c'est que je ne
crois pas tellement la réforme du cinéma
le sud il ya peut-être une réforme d'un
certain cinéma mais le cinéma disons que
moi j'affectionne que je pratique que je
respecte que je défends que je vends n'a
pas besoin de réformes celui là se porte
très bien et va très très bien
c'est quand même un cinéma qui fait de
l'argent non pas le cinéma qui fait de
l'argent le cinéma que les gens ont
envie de voir le cinéma qui fait recette
parce que les gens ont besoin de
spectacle que les gens ont besoin de se
divertir
je ne fais pas du cinéma pour les
chapelles ou je ne sais pas du cinéma
pour pour une élite je fais vraiment du
cinéma pour les cinéphiles mais de
france et d'ailleurs
merci alain delon nous verra donc nous
verrons donc le choc à partir de demain